you were nominated for the Best New
Artist Grammy thank God we didn't win
that and that's the curse right but you
know who won that year do you remember
Mariah Carey Mariah Carey yeah
did you okay she did fine most people
who get the Best New Artist Grammy curse
of death curse with that were you
nervous about winning that I mean we
don't win a war you guys never won an
award
I never but you don't seem all that
bummed out by it now you don't give a
[ __ ] the real reward is you loser
anything you listen to something you're
having the best night of your life
you're getting married it's a certain
song that you want to hear you know so I
think for me just to be a part of that
exchange you know to put out you know I
always thought it was you know I'm in
the same record stores Thelonious Monk
you know what I mean like you know to be
like how did that ever happen or any of
the groups we like whether it's you know
X or if Siouxsie and the Banshees or the
Cure you know there's a you know we like
so much stuff but just to be a part of
the be a part of the whole thing to me
has always been important you know more
important than like you know hey they
won the disorder that'll work back in
the day when you guys were making the
album's music was different the music
industry was different record companies
ruled the world you know you could sell
albums it was a different it was a great
time though it wasn't it it really was a
great time for plan to come out it was
and then it's sunk in the late 90s
because I remember going to Sony and
when we've switched and like these bands
would be out there trying to hail a cab
with their instruments and all the vice
presidents would have town cars circling
some right and that's when it it's
shifted and it became more about the
sort of ego and corporate ego and hubris
instead of honoring these musicians that
were coming and the whole thing was
built on I played us for every time
someone played our songs you know what I
mean right
again it's not about that but it'd be
cool to be respected I don't go to a
Broadway show and pull out my phone and
tape the thing you know that's right no
I really you think is the cheapest thing
for people and I don't understand how
people are okay with the fact that the
musicians put out records now nobody
pays me like
like the way the music business is now
there's less douchebags to deal with
right but tonight douche bag factor is
big there's a huge actor we does a new
show coming do you guys ever watch those
shows where like you know the boys or
you know American Idol the thing is I
don't watch people eeen kids with nice
teeth asking people to like me vote for
me I did I got into this job I was
unemployable you know what I mean I'm
part of being a musician and an artist
was there's an outsider culture